this year the Booga features 32 flower
exhibitions 50 themed gardens 55
hectares of parkland and one river the
hopper the river scape offers plenty to
discover as well it's a natural paradise
with a handful of towns on its banks
about a million and a half visitors are
expected this summer and the Havel
points the way the river links all five
locations of this year's Booga the
northernmost venue is the former
hanseatic city of Havel bag in Saxony
unhoused here the 14th century gothic
Church has been transformed into a
backdrop for changing flower shows
getting plants to blossom in a dark
church is a horticultural challenge our
light levels are between eight hundred
and a thousand lux we go around very
carefully with our watering cans we have
a historical floor here part wood and
part stone so we have to be careful not
to damage it my husband is OCD
the unusual venue is popular with
visitors Virginia Beach it's very
impressive to see so many plants in a
church I really like it
there's an exodus but we came here
especially to get some ideas for our
home we have season tickets and we plan
to use them to the max there are three
bicycle stations along the Booga route
and if you want to enjoy the scenery as
well as the flowers hop on a bike
follow the course of the Havel it's 40
kilometers from hostel beg too hot to
know for instance a comfortable day trip
not a--not lies near the midpoint of the
Booga root here the branches of the
half-full twine around the town's Park
it's 13 hectares in area a huge sea of
flowers a guided tour takes two hours a
woodland art installation pays tribute
to the focus of this year's Booga the
blue ribbon of the Havel the blue ribbon
symbolizes the river flowing from
Brandenburg to retino to half a bag I
think there'll be lots to see over the
whole year till October it's exciting
just fights for it I'm sure there are
highlights for everyone on highlight
it's another 40 kilometers from Gatineau
to the city of Brandenburg
this is the bougas southernmost stop a
town with more than a thousand years of
history a special sight here is the more
than 30 themed gardens featuring the
latest gardening trends many are based
on the bougas motto water
even finds fished out of the hovel
become art objects
and of course the floor of the region
plays a role in the herb garden for
instance
another focus is gardens in small spaces
it's kind of it's I can create something
with materials and artworks when I don't
need thousands of square meters to
create an attractive garden and I talked
even goblinses one River
five locations and a million blooms all
on show at the Booga until the 11th of
October